would have just been the middle-class
kid who made good Mike Bloomberg became
the guy who did good with this campaign
video former New York Mayor Michael
Bloomberg ends the speculation and
announces his presidential run jumping
into the Democratic primary race
bringing jobs and thousands of
affordable housing units with him in
some ways Bloomberg may be a formidable
rival money is almost no object for him
with an estimated net worth running into
the tens of billions he is one of the
wealthiest men in America and just days
ago he broke records spending millions
buying advertising time in TV markets
across the country eclipsing the other
candidates but he will face challenges
despite his middle class boy made good
story he is now firmly part of a rich
global elite vilified so successfully by
the Trump campaign in 2016 I've known
Michael Bloomberg for a long time if you
go back early on he had he said a lot of
great things about Trump but I know
Michael he became just a nothing he was
really a nothing he's not going to do
well but I think he's going to hurt
Biden actually but he doesn't have the
magic to do well there is nobody I'd
rather run against than little Michael
that I could take and he's used his
great wealth and power to campaign for
more gun restrictions which won't play
well in America's heartland but more
than anything else
Bloomberg's moves say something about
the existing field of Democratic
candidates a true frontrunner is yet to
emerge
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Bloomberg's ambition will be to overcome
his late start and shake up this
fluctuating race Democratic Party
members will be watching closely and
deciding if they believe he's got what
it takes to beat Donald Trump Hannah
Thomas Peter Sky News New York